Qua trường u quay nè không ăn đi CbH em cũng tạm 2 cho rằng chỉ tổng thống mi đồ năng trăm mới có đủ đòn bây để thuộc đển ngà chăm dứt trên sử.
Đông thời kêu gọi tháng tốt đến trên đà phán khi các cuộc tiếp sức gọi Washington bảo chờ năng tạo được nà đến trên trong cuộc chờ là phòng vận với hạn thường tần Rồi Tơ tại Kiat.
Ông CbH nói những vấn đề khó khăn nhất còn tổn tải cần được giải quyết ở cấp, quên thuốc cáo, thông qua cuộc gặp trực tiếp giữa tổng thống u quay nè và tổng thống ngà,
thông trong khôn cộng kế hoa bình gồm 2 mì điểm đảm đủ thảo lất chỉ còn một số kỹ t nội dung thành chốt chưa đạt được đồng thật.
U quay nè cho biết một tàn giúp nộng lực hiện nay, để thuốc đại đàn phán trước khi các yêu tổ truyền trị nói bộ tệ Mỹ,
đặc biệt là cuộc bầu cử giữa những kỳ làm phân tàn sự chủ ý của Washington.
Kiat sản sản định nhá kinh trình và đã trân thận để xuất của Mỹ về việc tổ chức vòng đàn phản bà bên tiếp theo tại Miami trong thời gian tự.
Tình bộ đồng CP2 đưa ra sau vòng đàn phản bà bên tại Abu Dhabi không đặt đủ phá.
Dùng á của quay nè đã nhất chỉ chào đổi bà trong mối bộng tụi bình.
Đây là cuộc chào đổi tụi bình đầu tiên giữa hành nước sau năm tháng.